greetings from podcast Ville kick this
[ __ ] muley it's Monday
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] Monday morning when my favorite
brothers is on here tonight the original
Sunday anarchy Dean [ __ ] bell
ring we're gonna discuss something that
a lot of people don't even know what's
happening I just realized I got a drunk
message the other night from a friend of
mine I'm not gonna say his name of many
years and this is what he said to me
Dean yeah those go go man I'm sitting
here I'm sorry I don't know what time it
is out there with those [ __ ] crazy
people cuz that's how he talks to me
he's like Jersey ain't no [ __ ] better
I'm over here living with my [ __ ]
mother making [ __ ] whatever working
at Home Depot cuz I can't get a [ __ ]
job because but I gotta tell you
something I gotta tell you something I'm
gonna regret for the rest of my [ __ ]
life not going to see ac/dc with you
that [ __ ] at night I [ __ ] them didn't
have the money because we went to get
him yeah you know that guy that's it
he's gonna go we went to get him you
threw rocks on his window oh yeah he
didn't have the ball and answered the
door he didn't have the 15 bucks yeah
and he didn't [ __ ] go see a CBC that
time and he didn't really want to go for
him so him to still hold it Wow I was
like what is he talking about and I hit
him back the next morning go what the
[ __ ] did you problem he goes oh man I'm
sorry what'd I say - I was a little
[ __ ] up I got nah
you were talking about a CDC couldn't at
that time when Brian Johnson took over
and I'm like oh my god he goes it's the
40th anniversary next week
I just heard it on some reason was
talking about it and he goes I just
realize how much fun you guys had had
because the next night we [ __ ] with
him like we tricked them told him a
bunch of Lies but it made me think about
that night and I know I've never talked
to Dean delray about that oh yes let's
educate the [ __ ] public and explain
to them what happened between you know
like August of 79 what happened February
19th
yeah and then for me it was August 1st
of 1984 you was a couple of weeks later
yeah break it down
well you know you got you got a record
that comes out highway to hell and for a
lot of people ac/dc was still an
underground band but the true rockers
were on to powerage Sin City was the big
kind of this is the tune and they put
out highway to hell with Bon Scott they
bring a new producer in Mutt Lange
instead of the uncles and this record
sounds unbelievable highway to hell and
then bonds God dies and to me back pain
of a singer died you were just like
whether that's it they're done nobody
nobody got another sing I mean the
momentum was just starting to happen
big-time people everybody's starting to
know Highway to Hell and then it was
just done how big was the highway the
whole tour explained the people it was
it was I saw them with Ted Nugent garden
it was big for me yeah it was big for me
to see a guy take a guitarist on his
shoulders and go through the orchestra
section and sing and go through all the
way around during the song I had never
seen that I had never heard that at the
time I wasn't Johnny experience in music
it's not like I had seen the doors or
anything like that but it was probably
my fifth concert and that made me like I
went there to see Ted but I left there I
hi whether these are high without fan
like I left there an ac/dc fan like I
went home until this day it's still my
best I think it's the best one-two punch
in music touch too much and whatever
walk all over you that's too much that's
the big on any album you know any anyhow
I think second is maybe Johnny Blade two
juniors eyes now I'll never say die just
have two songs that come at you that
you're like what the [ __ ] just happened
to my hair you know what the [ __ ] just
happened so take it from there I'm sorry
to interrupt you know it's it is true
it's just like diary of a madman where
you go into over the mountain it
Lyonne hi again Wow Ozzy but you know
they were big ac/dc but they hadn't done
the big room in San Francisco yet the
Cow Palace or Oakland Coliseum
they did Henry J Kaiser which is kind of
a smaller I'd say 7,500 seater it's
still there it's still there and that's
where I saw a priest Def Leppard you
know ac/dc it was just a smaller room
before you went to the big one but what
was happening with ac/dc that as an
older adult now in the entertainment
business they look at it they definitely
had somebody behind them that was really
working the Machine because at the same
time that was going they shot that film
let there be rock and that film if you
look at it is so Pro and the sound and
the look and everything and it was
played in movie theaters I mean I was a
kid bought a ticket and saw it in a
movie theater and so there was
definitely somebody behind this band
we're starting to work at new producer
radio here with highway to hell but
still not giant yet but really all the
cool people were listen to a CD see you
know I'm saying so you had heard of them
cuz usually you didn't go see the
opening band is what I've heard from you
guys well I had seen him like Joey open
for Ted Nugent but in 78 on the powerage
tour I went to go see Ted Nugent I
didn't know any of the other bands on
the bill and I left that day a fan of
everyone it was cheap trick ac/dc
journey with Steve Perry just joined
Blue Oyster Cult Ted Nugent that was
that was the first time I saw ac/dc you
know and I was just kind of like oh wow
all these bands I listened to to this
day from that one show but you know by
the time I'm into ac/dc from that day on
I'm a huge fan I get what to be if you
want blood the live record I just play
it day in and day out
so when highway to hell came out I
bought it immediately the day it came
out
so I you know I become a bond Scot freak
of course because everybody liked Angus
but I was looking at bond like who's
this guy he was the first guy saw it
tattoos in a band yeah now he's up there
no shirt on tattoos big old [ __ ]
tattoos which I read later he hated they
got him in the Merchant Marines I
thought he got him cuz he was like I'm
getting tattoos I'm a badass but he got
him into Merchant Marines he had a
parrot a big old parrot on his arm so
you know when he dies to me it's like
well this is done I've told the story
before the radio got it wrong I was
going to school it came on the radio
this just in Angus Young has died and
ac/dc
was my mom dropped me off at school as a
Kangas young died and then later on that
night I found out it was born and then I
had to look through the paper the
Chronicle it was in the back little
little [ __ ] thing Bon Scott died like
the next day you know I was like well
bond died there was no internet or
anything that wasn't on the channel 7
News they didn't care about ac/dc it
wasn't like first story up it was a dude
in a bang so he's dead and I'm like wow
it's over there really is over you know
there's there's no way you're gonna come
back there's no way you're gonna get
another singer and come back that just
didn't happen back then you know so in
March 26 van halen releases women and
children first record and I go well this
is you know I love them both I go this
is the band now women and children
incredible record this is it a CDs he's
done and there's no internet like I said
so you're not hearing that they're
looking for a singer I'm not hearing
that at all I'm not hearing they're
working on a record
none of that a matter of fact I looked
it up Joey last night because you were
saying hey you get your thoughts
together on it I don't even remember
them announcing they got a new singer
until about a week before the record was
coming out as I
a city's got a new singer and the record
will be out next week I my new singer
this is insane you know like and and I
mean just like now you know they would
have done a documentary the search for
the singer you would have saw a film on
it it would have been a million guys
coming down you were to be seen all
kinds of DeLuna see terrible people all
that but back then nothing and all
sudden I remember I was in Fresno my dad
lived in Fresno and I heard on there was
a station of Fresno called KK deejay
rock station it [ __ ] great
they said hey CDC's new album is out
tomorrow get it in all stores called
back in black
I rode a bus for an hour and this is
funny to think about if Fresno Fresno is
gnarly yeah Here I am
I guess 13 1980 13 years old rode a bus
all the way to Tower Records on
Blackstone Avenue in Fresno I walked in
there it was they were playing it you
know is this the guy yeah this is it
okay here and I just bought it and I
walked out got on the bus another hour
ride home just looking at it no photos
of the band it's inside I didn't want to
open it yet just a black cover the back
looking at the the song titles got home
opened it up I was weird cuz I would
just take the shrink-wrap and perfectly
slice it so I had the shrink-wrap so it
wouldn't get trashed it had that imposed
coke cover emboss cover the letters
opened it up slid it out there was the
photo of the band you know different guy
there's Brian hat down can't see what he
looks like he had a hat down just kind
of ah I put it on first song hells bells
I'm listening to it and I thought about
this jewelry last night for you I wish I
had a time machine just to go into the
state of mind of like it's complete
a different singer and it comes on uh
this is this is okay and I listen to the
next song and then I get an X I thank
you okay I play the record again second
time listen through okay I kind of like
this song yeah this one's good
I listen to it the third time my dad's
at work all day I'm just playing it I
called buddy long-distance call you know
do you what do you think I don't know
man it's it's okay it's good you know
and then the four time I remember there
was a song on there called let me put my
love into you great guitar great guitar
and it was like a song that they had
never done before they'd never done a
song like that and I was like I like
this one in hells bells and then from
that day on I listened to that record
and women and children back and forth
all summer and slowly I was like this is
a [ __ ] masterpiece it became a
masterpiece it's funny how I thought of
the two albums that became masterpieces
right in front of me back in black
two-second Def Leppard
oh hi and Ryan I took a long time for
that that's five when I could talk like
eight months okay who releases now and
either takes or it doesn't take right
they released it went on the road
started blowing people out of the water
you left that you want to get the
[ __ ] out like I've seen you know
British steel launch Judas Priest
yeah I'll bet for leather knocks on the
door British steel kicked the [ __ ]
door down and just said listen well
we're coming up with whips motorcycles
steam you know we're coming
it was just such a different time
breaking the law what are you guys
emotions like did you not want to like
the album no I was singer I I didn't
know what to think because I of course
I'm a bond guy
but you're talking about a different
vocal and the genius was he didn't
imitate bond so later on of course I've
become obsessed with ac/dc and I heard
that maybe the crocus guy was gonna
audition and I thought I'm glad he
didn't get it because he sounded like
Bond they did a genius move not getting
a bond sound alike I did read early on
you know here's this guy that's from a
band called Jordie I never heard of no
Jordie and I'm a music freak back then
he's in a band Jordie Bon Scott had seen
him one night and told the band [ __ ] I
just saw one of the greatest singers
ever if I'm ever gone you got to get
this guy yeah
and he said you're not gonna believe
this dude he's rolling around on the
floor he's going crazy and when they
talked to Brian about it he goes yeah
but he didn't know mate was I had
appendicitis that night so he was on the
for cuz his appendix burst and he's
singing like you know he didn't know
what was wrong with him he's just
singing the gig but his appendix
ruptured or whatever and so he was on
the ground and bond thought that was his
thing oh great is that but you know if
you listen to Jordie his other band he
doesn't sound like the Brian Johnson of
ac/dc so there's some serious genius in
there when they come in not lang I read
something that Mong Lang worked with him
[ __ ] detail by detail yeah that mutt
really I'd never even known what was on
that out oh my god I know mutt from like
the Def Leppard I'll write that I had no
idea but Lang was on that [ __ ] album
but I heard I read last night of the
night before just to be prepared for you
that mutt worked with him to have a
specific sound a specific they worked
really hard in the studio I think I
really don't wake it be I think I read
three different articles on back and
black [ __ ] all interesting the cover
elmo's didn't release it right the
covers
what right out of mourning for bonds
course but the record label didn't want
to release it because it was black they
said nobody would buy it guys gonna buy
it if it's black and ac/dc pushed pushed
pushed pushed and they released it July
25th it's a shame that has been 40 years
like that's why I'm doing this podcast
it's like a [ __ ] like uh I'm warning
it like it's been 40 [ __ ] years of my
life like I left
August 4th 1979 and I ran home and
bought I went out now I'm not gonna lie
I did not have high without before I saw
after the performance of him in the
audience and going through and a whole
lot of Rosie right all that [ __ ] I
[ __ ] went and my order was high with
a how dirty deeds no I will he'll let
there be rock and then I got power oh
yeah power rage really became like I
would how was something let there be
rock is brilliant
no but power rage was just something a
little different yeah it's got two jams
on there I normally wouldn't like it's
not my style he sold them to me yeah you
know get yourself a steady job so yeah
yeah that is just brilliant the lyrics
just the way he's spitting them all
can't even feed my cat social security
item from the rent man all this [ __ ] it
reflects on what's going on right now
right sheriff knocking on my door any
funny all the time flying crazy all that
[ __ ]
I just fell in love with you know so for
me it was like when DA's wife was in
here Ronnie James god bless his soul you
know a lot of [ __ ] happened we were you
and I were very lucky that we got to see
three major changing of a guard we got
to see Sabbat change guards
uh ac/dc changed guards and then Van
Halen and I summon but being in Colorado
maybe 85 I was a kid I was a baby
yeah and we used to have if you lived in
if you lived at the hotel if you were
security or a valet whatever those
people will carry luggage if you lived
in an employee housing you had a shared
kitchen and you had a share of living
room
uh-huh and we were all kids in there
like I was 21 or something the girl I
was with was 21 the other guy was 24 no
one is that one loser that was 40 yeah
and he was still about my man this is
teenager job don't remember that dude
yeah I still remember his first name was
like Brian and I remember who all watch
him like Michael Jordan [ __ ] somebody
up like it was one of those days when
Michael Jordan was on [ __ ] fire yeah
I think he was still in Chicago
I'll even [ __ ] though yeah he was
told Chicago he was either in Chicago in
North Carolina I just know we're
watching basketball because the dude I
hung out with was from North Carolina so
that's all he talked about like you
couldn't bring it I only talked about
North Carolina basketball coke and [ __ ]
yeah that's all he talked about he was
always what are those guys you're like
you got nothing else huh I love my
brother
him and his brother with my closest
buddies they would they were dynamite
but there was this loser guy that nobody
kind of like we get when you're 21
when I was 21 if you were 28 you were an
old man like absolutely what are you
talking to absolutely go get a [ __ ]
job like when I was 21 yeah I would look
at all the guys like what are you doing
it all the time I'm over here trying to
talk to this 22 year old you're
breathing down my neck
what's the matter you take it somewhere
else all right you [ __ ] out like if I
saw a 30 year old my blood pressure
would boil yeah
but when I was 21 I was a bar I was
talking to 22 year old chicks and I saw
you there with your greasy hair talking
about your car now you're a real estate
agent we just [ __ ] you up we were kids
yeah you would usually get robbed we
take you back then yeah there was rules
the older guys around would be an older
brother
there would be an old man's bar yeah
they would know this old man bar yeah
why are you here and then they come up
to you right Jimmy paid no Jimmy paid
you told ya take the football shirt off
and go be a father somewhere right go
bother somebody starting quarterback me
like how I see myself now like how I see
myself like when I walk into a place I'm
that old creepy [ __ ] man so when kids
come up to me like I'm mr. Diaz we like
to take a picture which I'm like are you
[ __ ] crazy your mother taught you not
to talk some people like me that should
be number one in your [ __ ] mind
because when I was 21 if you were 28 and
that was the bar you came up to me and
talked to me about something I like
definitely you like like Val Kilmer look
at that guy and eat when the guys both
got a place get out of kill him I had to
kill him I was like didn't say a word
Val said like four words in heat he
didn't have to talk look the easily so I
don't forget this idiot like Oh watch
and he's like so who else is excited
about Sammy Hagar Javed van Halen we all
like looked at them looked at each other
and looked back to the TV like it was
like wow I was like get too old yeah
you're 38 yeah I got I hate that yeah
when you were older you were trying to
fit in like I could see you being
younger and try to go up but you're
trying to work backwards don't work with
me get the [ __ ] out here and the time
machine and go [ __ ] yourself it's funny
I just people like even when you're like
20-some 125 just seems old yeah why this
guy doesn't know man you don't know
music yeah then you don't know music a
25 funny
now I'm 54 I'm talking music for a
living
Oh eros it's really uh I love that's the
only thing I've loved about this
quarantine is that I really got to read
bigger eyes my music scene a little bit
it was getting a little stale on my own
I had a reach out outside my normal
comfort zone I mean I even listen to
Johnny Cash live from Folsom whatever I
mean I did that many different things at
night like just to switch up the nights
cuz I get so [ __ ] bored at night
unless there's something good on TV that
I haven't watched it's um I look at the
team you like at 6:00 if I don't see hon
even though there was a fight on on
Sunday night
on Saturday night I never even know what
day it is yeah oh no no no that's
keeping me sane really is kind of music
like I told you I just we fell in love
with Jarra flies so cool Allison chant I
wasn't speaking of that I the producer
of Alice in Chains name is his name is
Oh God trying to blink right now Jorah
Dave jerden they've turned in my podcast
he was working in the studio on another
record where ac/dc was doing back in
black in the Bahama Bahamas yes and
muttley I ran into Mutt Lange and the
kind of the you know though kitchen area
it's hey what are you working on his I'm
working on the ac/dc
new ac/dc why couldn't he said well the
singer died he goes yeah they got a new
singer you want to hear it
Dave jerden told me the story on my
podcast he went in there and he said
they fired up a track and he was like
wow this is gonna be [ __ ] huge like
he was the first guy to hear it well I
couldn't even imagine what that'd be
like the band's in there they're
tracking oh you want to come in and hear
a track that's just head explode her to
me so there was a question I have for
you guys an obvious
you can't be like oh yeah in 40 years
it's still gonna be big but when you
were listening to it do you like think
this is this is a song I listen to
forever this is this is a classic like
because like some songs you listen to
another day they're gone in six months
but then some songs will be played
forever
the song gets played every day on the
radio well to me that goes back to the
mystery - of I don't know what kind of
machine was behind them but the way they
were releasing these singles over a year
period and they shot five videos for it
all in the same day you know the way
they released this in the game plan of
this record it brought on the longevity
because I'm not a shook me all night
long guy now but by the time they drop
that thun it grabs the entire planet and
you know you've got a classic tune this
tune was a hit hit tune you know that
thing you hear it right now every day
shook me all night long oh my god so I
mean when I heard it I knew that I was
gonna be listening to hells bells at
least that song for the rest of my life
I think it's one of the most brutal
brutal songs ever recorded I think
that's one of the hardest parts I'm
having with my age and my time on this
planet that you know I have serious in
the car it comes at the car yeah it's
not like I'm oh I know anything to get
serious it's my most enjoyment that I
have is that serious I'm heaven because
I listen to five or six stations I'm
locked into lithium you know I'm locked
into whatever metal a nation Ozzy's
boneyard Ozzy's boneyard I'm locked into
classic 80s or something like that you
know I'm logged into all these different
things and I just go we has been the
call of me I just go I just go I don't
know and it's till I find something and
you hear those songs whether it's you
shook me all night long
what the song that broke
recently about six months ago was on the
way to the store one night coming back
up Laurel Canyon and hearing don't you
want me baby bye
oh yeah don't you want me baby listen to
that song how many times is it playing
every day I still remember being at a
club in New York City which was a big
deal for a guy like me back that that
summer of 82 when that song came out and
me having a crush on a girl and her
going to get drinks for us and she was
walking dancing to that song and I
remember like I fell in love and I in
that car that night on the drive home I
was like Jesus Christ then I know then
that I would be listen to this 40 [ __ ]
years from now 38 years crazy
sorry about that 38 37 years ago it's
crazy now you know when I was when I was
growing up you heard music from the 50s
and Elvis Chuck Berry yeah that was old
to me that was as old as I went when I
listened to Chuck Berry and yeah what's
this that's holding sweet the Franklin
you know when I was a kid my mom had all
that [ __ ] at the bar
RESP ect and all that yeah I lived it
but fifties music was what I was
listening to when I in the 70s well that
was as back as I went you know yeah you
don't go past that you don't go past
that you didn't band stuff yeah I didn't
go past that I think okay it's like
totally now I'm a little bit mature but
there was a time something was black and
white
I wouldn't [ __ ] even consider it like
my favorite Martian has color episodes
yeah and black-and-white episodes I got
one point they switched like we're
coming to you in color
well now you got me yeah yeah yeah black
and white [ __ ] oh yeah book the [ __ ] out
of me when I was a kid my friend's dad
he refused her cuz he goes we paid for a
color TV
watching black-and-white yeah Wow like
now you got to eat your words cuz I've
got black and one the only black don't
white I would swallow yeah was I Love
Lucy Twilight Zone yeah and the Twilight
Zone Leave It to Beaver no I don't know
why
Barney five Andy Andy anything else
no and then I got older I had to go when
I settled acting I went back and looked
at all like that [ __ ] Rick Ramos made
me look at all that yeah hey yeah well
he was a gangster you know Oh James
Cagney white I started watching those
like in 98 white he nine I started
watching those and again you know what I
appreciate him from time to time I just
don't want to see him all the time like
Jailhouse Rock yeah
it's black and white if you don't watch
jailhouse rock just put a gun in your
mouth move to Portland put it gonna be
about all right I'm not an Elvis guy
really no listen bro there's a part
about there's a little little part of
Elvis that look you know the other day I
was watching the autopsy of James Brown
that was brilliant Wow that [ __ ]
died left his money to charity left the
white wife kids cut him off yeah they're
at the table like they couldn't believe
it he's like I leave my twenty million
dollars they're like yeah yeah to
charity here so a bunch of African
American kids I don't know yeah you Boys
and Girls Club of America [ __ ] get
your ass together and you you white hole
with that little black kid you should be
ashamed of yourself your mama shoulda
raised you better get out of here they
threw her off the estate he cut
everybody off but the truth is Prince
Michael Jackson
everybody robbed from James Bond not
robbed
I'm not saying wrong just bothering
influence today influence do you know
Messiaen Elvis yeah
influenced course a ton of people I get
all this was their here
because he is straight-out racist mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] job they [ __ ] they
mother [ __ ] John Wayne 30 years ago I
know now they shoot John Wayne now he
said how can you get canceled when
you're dead
yeah that's the one that really [ __ ]
kills me like you're dead cancel when
does it end
[ __ ] are you born the cannons over
[ __ ] man with John Wayne he's at the
cemetery right now looking at him how
does this work man putting a cannon you
know I know Nick Cannon since he's a
[ __ ] kid I know him since he's a baby
sitting outside we know what his parents
waiting for him to be allowed into the
improv you know listen Lee there's so
many anti-semitic [ __ ] out
there you know it yeah you know they I
didn't know it was such a big thing I
don't think he hates anybody I just
think he said something the wrong
[ __ ] way and if you guys have been
paying attention that happened to
somebody you know - you said something
the wrong way but to take away
everything for that you leave him with a
show that nobody wants to see what good
is that they show barely this to have a
singer I don't want to watch that [ __ ]
for you watching prison that's when
you're watching your present even I
actually get excited about that the
[ __ ] headless [ __ ] the master of
messing all right it's time for the mess
watch the hevesy yeah I wanna watch I'm
sorry I keep going Dean yeah you know I
think it was funny because you and I
were talking I looked up when I saw him
ac/dc
and it was you saw him a few weeks ago I
saw them the second night of the tour
right well they started July 31st rattle
Adelphia right on a father Thursday
we saw them Friday night at the
Palladium
on a Friday I saw him which is hilarious
so check this out I looked it up Joey
so they started they did a quick run in
Germany like a warm-up run it was like
eight dates then they did like six
States and Canada and then they dropped
down and they did Pennsylvania then
Philly like you said and your date was
the third date
palladium William I didn't see him until
September 5th so they had been cruising
around America and they came to San
Francisco and did the Cow Palace and
this was what's really crazy Joey I was
so young at the time they did two nights
they did the cow-house and the next
night they did the Henry J Kaiser which
is way smaller the same place they
played on hire at how I would have loved
to seen him at that [ __ ] place Cal
Palace is iconic and epic but the Henry
J Kaiser was half the size I never knew
until about a year ago when I looked up
the entire back and black tour it was
wild now I've looked at your set list I
wanted to see how much they were
changing off of the set list how crazy
is this top 38 years later 40 years
later we'll find them we could find the
set list of [ __ ] toys it's great I
[ __ ] love this million nights that
they do in New York they only did one
night I looked it up Friday night here
it is it's August 1st 1980 and you got
track 11 a song 11 in the set rocker
which I had never seen Brian Johnson
seeing rocker ever so early on they were
probably trying the setlist working
tunes in some Bond songs pull out the
setlist
here's your setlist hels belles they
open every show at hells bells it had to
bail promoters then they went into shot
down in flames hell ain't a bad place to
be problem childhood back in black bad
boy boogie ok I'll tell you on your
podcast what happened there in bad boy
ok Sam
to me Holloway yeah he's gonna [ __ ]
love it
Tom's gonna [ __ ] charm it okay highway
to hell what do you do for money honey
high voltage whole lotta Rosie rocker
TNT let the bee rock there's only a 13
song set but remember they had all the
guitar solos and everything so it's a
long show yeah now the interesting thing
on this tour was it's one two only three
songs from the new record which is
pretty wild from back and by now by the
time they get to me they do all the same
songs you got but I got which is really
cool
is I got TNT which is pretty cool and
shoot the thrill so they add another
song in from the new record you know so
it's it's pretty interesting to look at
this and I looked at the the to set
lights from the Bay Area they switched
one song they did the jack the next
night and instead of the Jack I got bad
boy but our TNT so pretty wild it looked
at crazy what's really crazy that we had
to go to the show to see what he sounded
like on the bond Scott stuff see that
was the test you know he opened with
hells bells this is [ __ ] great are
they only gonna play that back and black
record nobody knew do they just play
that record or what are you doing but no
they do hells bells and then they go
right into shot down in flames
yeah all right he sounds a little
different on this you know so you're
hearing the Bond stuff for the first
time live but it's [ __ ] loud it's
rockin that people are going crazy and
eventually you know he starts to get the
Bond stuff pretty damn good you know
there's nothing I love more and I
appreciate it more as a comic and I
appreciate it more now as a non comic
cuz now that were comics and we're not
doing comedy you look at calming a
little different when you watch it
that's
have been doing I've been dipping into
the old guys I liked and watching this
that's a little bit of Kennison [ __ ]
Rogen's podcast with Bob Saget was just
brilliant right listen to me oh yeah
yeah yeah it was just the I talked about
Bill Byrne yeah bombing it freely but he
really liked it at that Kinison style I
mean the Rodney Starr everything oh my
god he was saying some wild [ __ ] so I
went back and looked into all that and
you you know you look at the
presentation like how I love to be sold
bro I love for a comic I love for a band
I love for a woman I love for a man I
love for people to sell me I always have
yeah not with a with a gun but with
their artistic freedom you know like but
when you over you mean to win me all
right that's what I'm sorry I you know
I've said it on this show a thousand
times the who I leave the house to do
comedy from 2001 I started doing this
because the only way you could get good
as a comic is for cheering a few your
comics they're cheering for comics yeah
once you really start cheering for
Thomas you start growing once you really
tagging on one comic oh I'm gonna follow
this guy like his style I'm gonna see
what he does and you start managing his
career in your mind you know but I still
remember watching Tommy and then winning
me over you know Brian Johnson Ronnie
James Dio yeah Sammy Hagar you know we
would go getting you know opening bands
we would I had been so used to getting
one over I liked getting one over yeah I
liked Michael Jackson when I went to see
him when I left there I left there with
going you know what man that
[ __ ] is a bad [ __ ] say
what you want you know in 1984 I could
lie to you and make up whatever [ __ ]
story you want yeah I
I had mine I had whatever $19.99
whatever little require don't even know
what I heard yeah I wasn't a prince Kai
the [ __ ] song came out my friend
asked me to go see him when I left there
I left there a [ __ ] prince friend
yeah yeah that's the boy it didn't
matter
it didn't [ __ ] the matter what he was
playing yeah I could put him up against
anybody like I knew when I left Prince
in 1984 I could put him up against
anybody like that guy right there yeah
that little black dude I could put him
up to James up from I could put him in
the room with Glenn Tipton the best like
I knew it when I left that day he sold
me he told me everything he had to tell
me when I went to see the b-52s the
guitarist that died yeah well that's on
the first two out right yeah he [ __ ]
sold me IRA Clapton sold me you know I'm
saying the only I owe me Jesus Christ
first time I saw Tony Iommi I thought my
[ __ ] head was gonna explode yeah and
the second time was even better cuz I
knew the catalog I knew what was coming
at me I knew the depth the different
chords you know like when you this this
there's something about seeing a band
now I appreciate I [ __ ] hate it when
you [ __ ] heard it today when you
[ __ ] go to Dayton and you [ __ ] go to
Dayton Ohio and you lay your [ __ ]
soul on the line for a weekend and then
your [ __ ] agent booked you in Columbus
three weeks later and you don't know
which three hours from Dayton you're
finding out when you land
yeah what I was just there yeah and when
you walk off stage you had a great set
but somebody comes up to you and says hi
oh my god we went to see you in Dayton
do we sing on you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
they saw me doing the same [ __ ]
material now I get it
now I'm not man name yeah now I get it
because guys like you and I you know as
I got I started getting older I started
catching bands twice on tour
always always twice on a tour like you
get hip to the Dead coming back
Phillie in six months I am missing it
and I I would jump on the Philly wagon
and you go and you see what they
replaced what they didn't you know
tell Italy my first Ozzy show was at the
Palladium my second lousy show is at the
Nassau Coliseum with a [ __ ] castle
yeah it grew that much [ __ ] one year
yeah it was for dirty white dudes with a
Cuban 330 white dudes in the Cuban yeah
on stage that said no visuals no nothing
just rock so he came back a year later
with a [ __ ] cash lasers lasers laser
a [ __ ] [ __ ] with a bag like this
yes but whatever the lasers would spin
and say ASEAN it [ __ ] craziness ah so
now I understand when people would come
to see me and Dayton and after E weeks
later they would go oh we came to see
you doing and different artists who we
do different orders and [ __ ] however you
feel you walk on and you go oh [ __ ] I
hope I open with this tonight you know I
tell you what Joe I read a crazy story
on Brian Johnson's audition bit me so
his manager calls him and says a cdc's
audition and some people in London they
want you to come down he's got no money
none he's singing in this band Geordie
he's got nothing he goes I'm not going
out there it's like a an $18 ticket or
something a train ride I don't have $18
the manager goes I think I can get you a
commercial singing a commercial I think
it's for hoover vaccums it just came out
a month ago that somebody found it he
goes so you'll go out you'll sing the
commercial you'll make some money and
then stop in and do the audition because
I [ __ ] it I'll do it then you know or
else he wasn't gonna go if he didn't had
that commercial he wouldn't a god he
didn't have the money for a train ticket
to this day do you know anybody else
they auditioned I don't I don't like
that's what
that's what I want it now people always
go what would you pay for like what type
of content would you pay for you know
what kind of fella pay for the guitar
audition so house oh yeah yeah cuz it
was Michael Shanklin yeah I know it was
a bunch of savages that came in to that
audition yeah supposedly he called
Shankman nazi uh-huh and shame they ran
out of there oh not say it in German you
know I want to see ya those auditions
writing them what's that movie when you
know was based on Judas Priest rock star
rock star yeah I love that I love that
moves great I love that boy yeah I love
that [ __ ] move how you had to go in
and adjust you know that type of stuff
has always made my dick hard why did you
go with him you know this guy left you
replaced him with that guy you know that
type of [ __ ] is funny how if you go
online and look deep you could see the
first singer Black Sabbath had for house
II before Ronnie James Dio oh yeah was
god-awful oh it was like two of them it
was god-awful Paul Walker or sometimes
Barker something weird is his name yeah
yeah yeah it is god-awful this two slums
on that on YouTube you gotta look wow I
haven't heard that really close yeah
they had a bad boy Brown oh that guy he
was a singer from Savoye Brian
he was Black Sabbath he did like two
songs they had a meeting listen
yeah here's a dollar don't come back
here's a table train station go over
there where they hit people with ax
handles down the corner go where they
take the train home
am I still in the band yeah yeah yeah
we'll call you it's like the guitar
player yeah and Motley Crue the chaplain
dude the first the first guy would make
bars well the Chinese guys Soundgarden
that quit after the first out the bass
player the best he's great yeah he sang
this an awful water that guy was [ __ ]
for no
Oh oh I tell you it funny another funny
story is you know those guys they they
[ __ ] they go out there they get him
in the band and then he's got to move
out there you know the reason gave me
money to move at the time it's not like
they're loaded you know no even even
Rudy has told their stories yeah when he
came out with Randy Rhoads and they put
him up in a hotel yeah it was you know
it's like us being comics yeah
the first time you got on a triple one
you know for two years you've been doing
[ __ ] places your buddy Agostino calls
you for a backyard yeah Steve someone
calls you for this but now you go on the
trouble and you got your own hotel room
every night and you feel [ __ ]
invincible you know you just feel it's
touring man yeah it's all part of it
there you go on a different hotels and
Tribble runs their [ __ ] dumpster look
for the worst hotel in town that's where
you're staying or dribble yeah doors
don't lie water's cold
bedbugs see the bedbugs the windows are
broken like I can't imagine going on a
trouble run now I can't imagine doing
all the dates on a motorcycle now like I
did you know I think about that all the
time of like man I was riding in the
freezing cold or the boil and heat or
the [ __ ] sandstorms
doing date I mean I can't even imagine
that now have you felt lately how is
true my next I am I'm pretty [ __ ]
good I know you mental state with all
that's going on comedy yeah it's been
three and a half months for you all so I
know you keep in touch of mark and and
Bill and stuff how is it going your
world that's [ __ ] horrible I can only
play it off so much you know it's just
uh I mean I'm alive I've got my health
and there's people that are way way bad
but I'm not gonna lie man it was my life
and it's just God it's completely gone
so I sit home a lot of tonight's and
think wow what a what am I gonna do I
love my podcast
so I'm throwing all my energy and
creativity into my podcast and my
patreon people I'm doing live zooms with
them and that's really helping me as
much as it's helping them you know
Saturday night I do zoom fest instead of
re shroom fest and I get the patreon is
up there and we do ship Missoula on
patreon office I love it and it's a good
idea well it's good for me it's good for
them I think that uh you know there's
people that aren't seeing people you
know the amount of work and talking the
cowork right and it's great you talked
on the phone and stuff listen I try to
check in with as many people as I can
but I also in a way try to check in
social distance if I can with people go
yeah what a face to say sometimes yeah
six feet away even with a mask on cool
you know we're cool you know it's I
think it's when you gather I think
that's the big thing that's enough I
think that's the problem but I'm a
scientist and I don't know if I'm
avoiding it I am in a great position
that I could avoid it I pray for people
yeah you know if you go to hit an hour
burger we lit those huts there's no
social distancing in that heart now
you're gonna eat a cover on a burger
it's its eminent yeah one day some guys
are going there I attend the morning
chopped up onions tell her he's gonna
say something - Lee hey what's up how
was the movie last night you're in the
hut this big cooking for eight hours
going in the air
that's gonna spread like contamination
yeah I'm not putting them down I'm not
saying nothing bad about it and out I'm
just no you know when I Drive past it
cuz the goodwill is over there yeah so
whenever I turn around and the goodwill
is [ __ ] closed it is cause it's
[ __ ] closed
yeah I want to dump [ __ ] off again but
close yeah I had to take it to a
different men's shelter it's [ __ ]
crazy yeah
shit's [ __ ] closed man are you what
do you see for I mean what do you see
for the comedy in the next six months
do you see yourself lying do you see
yourself driving well I really don't I I
really have no idea uh as much as I look
it's easy for me to do comedy right now
I talked to you about it you pull up
behind say the Bray improv you walk
through the kitchen you walk on stage
you do your set with your microphone you
walk out and you wait in your car for
the next show that's easy to do to stay
safe to me it's more about the fans
I can't imagine they're gone so crazy
they want to get out of the house that
they're not thinking and the venue
maybes not thinking all all the way
together bathrooms the line everything
and then they get in there and somebody
gets sick and you know dies or something
I just I just couldn't live with that
you know I just you know it's like so as
much as I want to do comedy and I want
to help the people you know besides
doctors comics are the next people that
everyone looks at to help them mentally
and you know when they're in a bad state
when when America is in a bad state when
9/11 happened and everybody was like
whoa comics helped you know when when
something tragic happens comedy helps
ease it it's right after doctors in my
eyes and here we are these guys that
have been doing this for years and we
can't help people so it's horrific to me
that we can't and I'm not going to do a
zoom show it just it doesn't so I'd
rather just zoom hang I'm not gonna do
zoom comedy it's just not no it's it's
not I'll zoom hang with fantastic how
about it just to get to know people in a
[ __ ] half-hour you know
mercy goes to bed at 9:00 where a wife
goes to bed at 9:30 perfect I'm alone
yeah not alone
so I write you know I try to [ __ ]
stay away from the TV oh yeah as much as
I can I don't know I'm just between the
TV the other day I saw something that
was so [ __ ] bad on Twitter I almost
canceled my account know how somebody on
Twitter wrote 10 July 30 it's all the
benefits we're gonna run out he couldn't
wait so you can see a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] dry up like a spongebob like
spongebob was something like that and I
looked at the guy's name it was a real
account yeah and I'm like what would
make somebody write that how [ __ ]
miserable people so that's evil there's
evil in the end I'm scared of two things
by going on the road number one
obviously Coronas spreading crisps and
number two the uncertainty we as
Americans were very uncertain right now
what having issues you know I don't know
what you're thinking you know you might
seem great to me but you haven't paid
rent in four months right and the share
is knocking on my door ain't it funny
how the time fly yeah you know I don't
know what you're going through
yeah you know these people I know I know
it's the [ __ ] 20th of the month and
I've been seeing moving trucks I rode
the bicycle on Saturday and Sunday and
I've been seeing moving trucks so what
does that tell me people are abandoning
ship yeah that's the route that's the
number they're not giving you the people
are leaving that way because Lee and
Steve some loans from moving trucks
three a day yeah all the [ __ ] June
and July you know what I don't
understand nobody's talking about is
this entire city is built on the
business the cameramen the the set
carpenters the makeup people the extras
the script writers and that's zillions
of jobs no one's working it's about to
just completely
buckle and people are like well when's
the club's opening back up drives me
crazy I'm like wait it tries to be great
what are you talking about
people don't have jobs right now yeah
charge me crazy like there's a limit you
could push yeah there's a limit you
could push you know like I said before
when you drive down Melrose it's gonna
take two years for me to see my mother
like that the guys in that company came
and we did dabs with them and the
restaurant was packed behind this do you
know what man I'm talking about
yeah I'm not Rose you know I want you to
close your eyes and think about that
night we crossed the street on Melrose
he took out a [ __ ] torch and we
started dabbing with those rows Goodman
Sumana those goomy's hermanos my Peter
yeah goomy's hermanos and his brother
came down here and I was thinking about
that and Lee and I and those four guys
their two wives and six fans you know we
run across the street and everybody was
smoking pot we don't I think I had done
a spot there like I was just doing a
spot there right but how busy was the
place leaving the parking lot was busy
yeah then there's a restaurant across
the street yeah
and we were there gone Lee and I would
20 feet from that [ __ ] blowing [ __ ]
in there dad-dad smoke tell him I did
one dad but I [ __ ] went deaf and I'm
like this ain't for me
you don't say yeah I'm scared of the
fiery [ __ ] yeah but I just take my mind
to that and go okay that was like a soft
night in Melrose that was like a
Thursday night we had a lot of fun we're
all by eleven yeah but what I'm trying
to say is there was action when will I
see that action again alright so now you
got a definitely think November till
after the election
right right with already talked about
the election but then you're looking at
cities like Philadelphia who have
canceled entertainment till march of
2021 yes that's you know you normally
cities are gonna jump on board with that
like little entertainment till [ __ ]
February that's exactly one year that's
exactly one year well that's
March 12 yeah my heart goes out to the
club in Philly
oh uh helium yeah are close out to me
called me a few weeks ago he was doing a
contest like a comedy contest and stuff
like that that closed for [ __ ] it by
the way I want to give a big shout out
to Jimmy's seafood
I took an edible one night with Lee and
I got [ __ ] up and I was craving
[ __ ] crab cakes that's one of those
nights you gotta take the credit card
away from me and I bought some crab
cakes online my wife I woke up the next
day huh and they [ __ ] hooked me up
Jimmy's crab cake is in Baltimore
they're [ __ ] tremendous when I went
to Baltimore I actually went there that
good friend of Ryan Sickler and let me
tell you something their delivery comes
like a day later but they hooked me up
with some crab soup which I ate the
other night when I had the edibles with
a bunch of saltine crackers they got
[ __ ] the best crab cakes [ __ ]
better than Phillips [ __ ] Phillips it's
Jimmy's crab cakes [ __ ] go to Jimmy's
seafood Jimmy's seafood that's Jimmy's
seafood but they got the best crab cakes
don't forget to talk I still the [ __ ]
tacos what's the name night 1986 I saved
mine I got another one on there huge
fans here I love them I'd like to stop
in there and shake during joy you go in
there [ __ ] like 8 times a week I know
I told him I was like I gotta get out of
here
I I want to turn into a bond I have the
plate and everything they got like the
rice and bean play no they don't [ __ ]
around it straight Tijuana style taco
quesadilla and the vampire Rosa what
else yeah they don't [ __ ] Vampira it's
like a it's like a like a tortilla then
the meat and then a comments like a
sandwich and then another tortilla like
melt cheese on top they do yeah
and then they got the topo Chico and
they got the [ __ ] they got a secret
menu - if you say give me the one of the
secret one with the beans they'll do the
tacos with beans and that's so good man
ah love it
I've checked them with you every day
during this corn I love everything uh
you've made me smile because I know I've
been feeling some boy so some days it 2
o'clock you just look at that Sun and
you're like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
can I leave it where's Brody yeah
where's the rope at what Brody leaves
ropa this is terrible I mean this is
[ __ ] horrible and like I said you
know my wife is she's already started
the [ __ ] process man we'll get the
bank loan the whole [ __ ] they can't
believe you're moving man yeah we don't
know where yet but I told you that I
said you came over
I told he in edwardses story I got Joey
called me and when he calls me and says
where are you at I'm coming by he never
comes by
yeah he never comes I something's up so
I go downstairs I meet up front you pull
out you get out of your car and you go
we're out of here Dean
and I said what I didn't understand what
your time yep we're moving and I was
like whoa but I get it I said this about
a hundred times this week if everything
in LA that we love that makes it worth
the highest gas in America the highest
car insurance the highest rent besides
New York and San Francisco if everything
is gone that we love it's a level
playing field now every city is the same
now you got to find a spot that's cheap
that you enjoy being inside now it is
about the house or the apartment you
live in it's not about the city or the
town because you're going to be inside
because there's nothing
going on so it's a level playing field I
looked up gas prices in Arizona dollar
82 I looked up gas prices in New Jersey
148
I looked up you know saying gas prices
here $4 so you can go somewhere yeah I
live here because I absolutely love it
the weather my friends and in the stores
in the end they in the clubs and the
rock and roll I love everything about it
but if it's all gone I need to live
somewhere where it's uh it's cheap and
like I said it's a level playing field
now every city's the same every city's
the same some have snow some have
[ __ ] tornadoes tornadoes I have a lot
of homeless yeah
some have it's just and I'm not you want
me to tell you something I had to write
it out I'm not even sad about leaving
right there's one say I'm sad about yeah
you know he's 82 I want some little more
cancer for 10 years but you gotta
remember when I moved here the plan was
to fail pack my stuff yeah
stop over by him stab him in the heart
and then again the car mats in the jury
took me 25 years to come up with the
courage to apologize yeah and it
apologized to a lot of people I 25 it
took me 25 years to the date almost 25
years in a month and I got a call in
[Music]
2009 2009
what's 24 84 84 and 2009 I got a weird
call for a movie that actually paid yeah
like it was like that after the writers
strike them all hundred-dollar day
movies yeah but I got a call to read in
Malibu and I [ __ ] went to Malibu
Malibu where the hall what a weird way
weed yeah that's the first time I ever
read
check yeah and I will out their rent
read for them the drive back I go I know
this spot you know like I know this spot
and I pulled over to the spot that go
why do I know this spot I go my uncle
brought me here when I was a kid a
couple times this is the beach we would
go to yeah and I [ __ ] worked out my
phone I never forgot his number I called
him when he answered and I told him in
Spanish listen this is I was a Antonio
don't hang up on me
I just want to tear when I came out in
1984 I was [ __ ] up and I'm embarrassed
for what I did to you I just want to
apologize like a man I live here and how
I have lived here for the last yeah 20
years yeah you know I'm a comedian I've
been in movies you could look me up and
you have my number you want to meet with
me call me back and he goes no no let's
talk and we started talking and then we
met up at his bar that Saturday night he
had like a weapon didn't know if I was
crazy we've been you know he answered
all the questions I needed answered
about my mother
yeah I family my life I was you know he
he's old so the phone rings from him
vitam the other night we call music are
you sleeping are you man I don't know
what I wanted to tell he is I just got
off the phone with my uncle and it was a
brutal hour ah I'm Spanish he's talking
about cookie Rojas it's like when you
talk to your father
yeah and it's an hour when yeah when I
talk to my uncle like I gotta like wipe
my hands for an hour it's gonna be an
hour conversation yeah okay it could go
the baseball music black people racism
yeah [ __ ] with him he's so [ __ ]
great to talk to her like he's told me
about all my cousin's all my uncle's my
sister you know my sister he filled me
in on you know his own sisters what my
mother's brother's you know he filled me
and I don't know my grandfather did my
grandfather was a junkie
yeah I like the junk and fixed it and
sold it on the street secure but ah
tourist you know yeah he was great he
was a hustler you know he goes that's
where you get it from your grandfather
this week he called me up he's like do
you have a minute I got it I know what
he talking like was I got it he goes
full of last [ __ ] two years I've been
banging my head off the wall figuring
out who you look like oh I got it he
goes Rosita he goes you and Rosita have
the same cheats on the same nose just
like your daughter I've been sitting
here for hours comparing the picture he
just goes off on tangents huh and he'll
call me why he's eaten eats peanuts
every night so I get him breaking
peanuts and he gets mad as he's talking
to me he talks to me about racism ah
they treat him badly in Cuba Oh a dog
pissed on him one time oh that dog
pissing on him changed his life yeah it
brought him good luck the other kids all
died but the dog pissed on justice [ __ ]
dig so deep and so he's so he has so
much wisdom right so the other day I was
just sitting there and I was like making
like an Abraham Lincoln clothes like
when you write down the good stuff yeah
and the bad stuff and I gotta tell him
and I broke down I had hit my cousin
with an email I told her first and she
was like bro he's really gonna miss you
oh yeah I go you don't think I'm that
[ __ ] molded me ever since I've
been talking about him yeah I've done a
lot better of my life like I got happier
after every conversation because he
answered he even answered some hard
questions I had to ask
yeah that warm Pleasant time he answered
them all like a man so I told my wife I
go my relationship with him during this
whole comedy thing for the last 11 years
has been gold don't get me wrong we've
had our disagreements of course we've
we've broken up twice and those 11 years
three months we won't talk to each other
you know because I told him one night he
got pissed at me yes I know what to do
the bar
well and I was all [ __ ] up I'm reefer
them like tio want you can hook it down
there and we'll sell some coke get the
Mafia down there he's like stop at the
Mafia up on me that's the only thing
yeah that would really break me down is
saying goodbye to that [ __ ] Weezer
because it's legit that's the end of my
family tree yeah once he goes that's it
I love my cousin's I don't talk to my
cousin's right I talked to a girl you
know our relationship never really blast
and we never really had time he's a
school principal I talked to my cousin
she got mad at me wanted twice but my
cousin came to a couple sets she came to
see me shoot a few movies a few TV shows
so her and I had cool she really loves
mercy so yeah that that's what I'm gonna
miss I'm gonna miss the thing that's
kept me together the thing that helped
me become the man that I am today in my
uncle um I miss him a lot
we talk a lot about a lot of [ __ ] and
you know now but that's it man how can
they find you podcast Wednesday so today
today okay podcast led to be talk I've
got darryl dmc' on the show today
really yeah Wow great episode of that
guy the legend legend from Run DMC
Darryl DMC you are [ __ ] Savage yeah
you moved over this thing and you're
looking for the cheapest apartment yeah
I always talked about you in the park I
tell people I used to walk around the
streets of New York with your backpack
yeah waiting for a hotel tonight to open
up tria
you know waiting the same 100 hours and
you call me when they're like from the
[ __ ] lounge and whatever
yeah you look I gotta $49 dude right you
have to stand man I would sit in the
stand tall around 1:30 and there it is
boom cheap hotel on hotels tonight you
know you're gambling on that but you
know I I'm glad I did the 10 years of
comedy and I'm still doing comedy
I mean if we get a vaccine it's on it is
on but if we weren't ever able to do it
again it was the greatest ten years of
my life hands down it smoked everything
I did in my life I've done a ton of
great [ __ ] but nothing comes close to
the comedy the fans that I've met and my
friends you Bill Maher and Ian you know
the the fit of the Comedy Store family
all that it's just I'll never forget it
I just remember one thing because I was
beat myself up a little bit last week
and I gotta be as honest as I can with
you my deck is art yeah my dick is hard
I'm gonna tell you why because I was
focusing I'm not doing comic again the
reason why we do this [ __ ] podcast is
to [ __ ] you know put butts in the
seats no not to open people's eyes yeah
I want to open people's eyes I did this
podcast to [ __ ] reverse my thinking
this is my therapy you know so the
therapy was this I always beat my heart
okay I came on the podcast last week and
actually it said what you said like I'm
miserable without stand-up which I am
yeah I really am
and we don't have a [ __ ] crystal ball
now we here at the church you Bill Byrne
Ali Wong we don't have a crystal ball
but nobody could call when you're gonna
stress yeah I can go on a driving tour
and you have you big people horn at me
and then you know what when it comes
back it comes back and guess what I got
a second chance to start over
yeah how much fun is that gonna be yeah
it's gonna be nice I thought about that
that gonna be completely whether I move
to Tennessee Indianapolis Texas
everywhere there's a subculture of rooms
yeah
like somebody's got a subculture room of
course again in Phoenix they got you
know the House of content be improv
Dafina simple but there's a chubby
Mexican
who's got three bars yeah and he pays 40
bucks and that's just fine because guess
what I'll be worth 40 bucks yeah I don't
wanna make people pay $25 to come see me
grand Xerox
right now so I'm looking forward to this
I hope I hope that everything works out
and the Comedy Store does open because
that's the perfect place and the start
from Ground Zero toad oh oh that would
be I would jerk off on the way down the
hill I'm blowing the original room to do
and then you just call it Monday through
Friday yeah that's it becomes brand-new
again a new job Monday to Friday yeah
take the weekend off because you're not
worth it you're not worth it to perform
on Saturday yeah yeah yeah you really
were yeah I feel the same way I'm
looking forward to start over
yeah when that date is I have no idea
but you know what I can't worry about
that I can make myself stronger today
Monday January the 20th I can just make
myself stronger a couple push-ups maybe
write something do I have the clarity
and the focus to write comedy crack a
few jokes with me I can bust your balls
a little bit yeah but to write a set
I haven't taken that much out for brain
yet yeah you know I'm saying by the way
I brought you some new mood hands cuz
you said you have a problem sleeping
yeah I brought you some key huh call
Keith Coco these things are [ __ ]
tremendous I read would set them so tell
people what's in it
cannabis infused botanical mints
microdose this is great how three
milligrams of CBN which Joey said the
CBN is different than CBD it's a it's
another even another level two
milligrams of THC so this would make
good sleep in here that's all you need
that's all you need that's a guy like
you does not get hot now two milligrams
you start with two yeah I need a half a
one you take your CBD lion sleep mints
yeah I guess see thinking lion like
crazy
you do it you you don't get hooked on
those you want one one night you see
weed alignment the other night yeah so
nothing really sticks no three nights in
a row
you done you're not gonna wait melatonin
that works for [ __ ] if you drink it
yeah what's a drink that people used to
drink to energize themselves I've
already all that red balls Red Bull yeah
people feel like getting cancer you know
yeah red balls in a rush
yeah why you know Rushmore wants to stay
up for ten days now do Matt stop stop
with the [ __ ] people do the real
stuff yeah if Red Bull does something
your [ __ ] boys its weak yeah if you get
off the 12 hours on Red Bull oh yeah go
eat Ranch Dressing what you know it
would be funny Jay I look forward to
like maybe in two years when someone
says man you became a better comic after
the kovat yes I look forward to that I'm
not depressed no more back looking at it
from that perspective yeah changed
everything
yeah yeah I'm a little bored oh yeah I'm
not sad anymore now I don't have that
little brokenness no more I had it for
about two weeks I'm not gonna lie nobody
I was looking at me a little hard that
you know this is a listen and then you
guys know it if you were doing something
if you're listening to this if you were
doing something for five years and you
stopped losing your job how do you feel
yeah
think of 29 having a family and having a
calmly families what I mean I'm we want
a family how many how many family that
you haven't seen and now little by
little they're balan now the waitresses
are starting to bail I tell you what
though the kovat as bad as it is it was
probably good thing for me because I was
talking to Maren about this where I
couldn't take a rest and I couldn't take
a vacation or anything because I was at
this point in my career where you can't
you can't so guess what yeah we're
always a temp always
that's a mark said yes day you start
calmly yeah really really calmly you'll
see it the day you really fall in love
withh calmly you'll feel yeah you see
when you saw the TV you downsize your
apartment cuz you're used to it you're
getting ready for the apocalypse
Tara your own personal apocalypse you
control it you shut off everything you
know what I love calmly so much I'm
gonna move into the [ __ ] office and
join the YMCA and take a shower
absolutely and pay 750 $50 I get a rent
and I live how I wanna live I don't eat
in here so you don't get rats right you
eat outside you know in the corner you
know but that's what you do vision man
horse track the church the course is a
Kentucky Derby man it's right here this
is it
so one good thing is my neck is [ __ ]
about 95% great my blood pressure is
completely back to normal it's unreal I
know that when did it raise it raised
right around when the neck injury
happened because they say when your
body's injured your my press and and I
couldn't get it under control man I was
exercising every day and I didn't need
any salt or anything and I never had
high blood pressure and you know lack of
sleep getting up at 5:00 a.m. to get an
uber to LAX oh my god it's gonna be
cancer [ __ ] yeah man and then you know
gotta get new material gotta get gigs oh
I gotta make money all that had it
cooking and now it's just level and now
we control what we want to go tell it
all right we're old the comics yeah we
control exactly yeah I want to go
don't forget Saturday is 40 year
anniversary of back and black and for us
it's gonna be a great day I'm gonna
[ __ ] celebrate it I'm gonna smoke
some reefer maybe do some type of
[ __ ] tube I don't know what but uh
it's gonna be a [ __ ] it's phenomenal
but I even lived to look back at it I'm
sad feel the same that's what I can't
believe we're alive I can't believe I'm
alive to look
back of it you know Timmy Holloway and
my brother he's listening to this I want
this podcast is dedicated to him he's
gonna have a rough week this week and my
heart goes out to my little brother
Timmy
I want to thank beamed or Izzy I want to
thank my men to Christ killing I want to
thank you [ __ ] I got no dates
but like Dean I got a patreon.com slash
Joey Diaz $1
I want the commitment no more [ __ ]
around no more idiots saying that they
trust me the comments I've read lately
on Facebook and Twitter
have been [ __ ] disgusting so I'm
keeping it simple video zooms blogs
vlogs whatever the [ __ ] you need a
dollar it's me
slinging dick take a chance Columbus did
I want to thank Dean Delray yeah I want
to thank the [ __ ]
and I want to thank you [ __ ]
stay black kick this [ __ ] mealy
[Music]